oh man oh man we are so close to one
another
do guys who are strangers just pee in a
big trough together I can be a little
pee shy
I especially RP shy I am oh yeah maybe
if everyone around us is doing it is it
hard not to look is it weird if you look
I want to look like I'm sorry if you're
gonna be right there and you're this
close please no don't I am interested to
see if I'm going to like if we can talk
if you're like not making conversation
the weird thing I talk when I'm nervous
I don't know what I would do with my
pants if you pull them down like if I
walked in and saw someone's butt I mean
that it's changing everything
we don't have zippers you know how do
you do that what are you learning please
can you just walk in and there's a man
but oh my god this morning and we made
these urinals door just like these
little bed pans and we have three of
these for each of us do be Bonnie
experienced or nice
yeah I'm ready to try it this is a step
in women's exploration oh man oh man
this is so intimate I'm ready together
okay we got me let's do it let's do it
okay okay so I see every minor little
lower than my but I can't tell if I like
still talking or if I don't like gel
cough ah dude why are you so good I
really had to go I hear it
I'm VIP no no a happy Jane was this
weird at all for you no I thought it was
actually easy well I think I'm gonna
give up I don't see it I don't think
like I could go anymore all right zip up
isn't a lot closer than you think
oh yeah yeah I would definitely tighter
Dee than I thought I looked in for Jamie
and she's like I'm like well [ __ ] if she
can do it I want you to think I really
realized how guys do this in a lot of
aspects my still don't understand it
must be really hard not to yeah I feel
like the one hard thing is when you're
trying to like beat fillet and like a
little conversation you look and if you
look at someone's eyes you're just you
do I'll secretly look and just pretend
like you don't you have to right I don't
think you have to I don't think they
totally make a quick check I like the
only thing that we're missing or I could
do that all of a sudden for you just had
a little dispenser with just a little
piece of toilet paper clip and then done
just one square yes